there is an immediate reflex in many
people's minds now to shut down as soon
as one mentions
religion
um and in this country which is a
godless country compared with
america no doubt canada
if you ask people do they belong to
religion about 13 of them say that they
do
um so 87 are not but if you ask people
do you think there's more to this
life and to this world than is accounted
for in the reductionist materialist
picture 95 percent of them say yes so
people are missing something extremely
powerful
and what is
wonderful in what you said and i
completely endorse and have written
about in a number of places
is this idea of being attracted forwards
to something that we wish to imitate
and it's in complete contrast to the
mechanistic
universe in which we are to play things
of causality
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
all right and so um before we start
maybe uh i would i think that i would
really like to most of your interviews
i've seen have been very much about the
brain and about the left right uh
hemispheres but when i i read i haven't
read your recent book i read that his
master the and the mathematician
um you can be forgiven for not reading
the latest one rather long but
so the the the a large part of the book
does discuss uh art and art history and
you know culture and i think of course
that's the aspect of your work that
interests me the most and so if you're
okay yes i think we will talk about i
mean obviously we will touch on
on on the brand difference but i will
focus mostly on the the question of
culture and the problem of
something like the the problem of
alienation of the modern of the modern
experience and and how you
how you try to trace that through
history and everything and you'll see we
probably have some similarities and
differences in the way we kind of we see
it and so hopefully it'll be an
interesting discussion
no that's fine um
i should just mention that the new book
uh doesn't have much in the way of
cultural history in it because i felt
i'd done that one
instead what it is is um an unpacking of
the philosophical consequences of two
bits of our brain as it were giving us a
different phenomenological world to live
in and so if we're asking questions of
truth like what
you know who are we i start this new
book with platinus's
question but we who are we because i
feel we've completely lost any sense of
what a human being is what the world is
like and how we relate to it so if one's
going to answer those questions then
the question of which one of the
hemispheres is telling us something we
can rely on better becomes important and
i just unpacked that so a lot of things
that you are very interested in i deal
with in part three of the new book
things like consciousness matter values
sense of the sacred
um and all those things well maybe we
can we can actually start there then
because i think one of the biggest
effects that your
your book has had
and your influence has been to
reverse the the
reverse the hierarchy of what is prime
primordial in terms of what it is to be
human and what it is to be to have a
human experience in some ways it kind of
overturns the the reductive scientific
vision that we've
that we've lived with on and off i guess
since enlightenment there's a
competition it seems between different
visions but definitely that's the one
that seems to have pervaded popular
culture you know this kind of reductive
aspect idea that we're
that we are almost just machines
basically you know
soft machines or something like that but
you really have been able to
bring about the the primacy of
consciousness and the
the embedded experience as being
something uh you you constantly
emphasize the notion of of context and
how things of into the interrelation of
things and that is how we
actually experience our the richest
part of our experiences in that so you
can start a little bit with that and we
can move on to the art and culture a bit
afterwards
absolutely we can start anywhere and go
anywhere that you like
i mean of course it's very nice of you
to say that i've affected some sort of a
shift but of course i'm just part of a
lot of people who've got rather um tired
of being served up this incredibly
simple-minded idea the reductionist
materialist position
um
and so i'm very glad to be part of a
movement for something a bit more
sophisticated and more likely to be true
um
but you you touch there on a very
important point of context
because
it seems to me that context is
everything it completely changes the
meaning of what one's dealing with
um
the context of a word alone can make it
mean something quite different but all
the things that are really
most powerful for us things like the
sense of
the divine of nature of love
poetry music and the rest can't easily
be
just made into explicit
sentences in
um
in prose the only way we can approach
them using language seems to me to be
obliquely
definitely and
the there is you know the the way that i
that i like to approach it is
there is a sense in which analogy is the
basic
mechanism by which we understand or the
way we engage
yes and so analogy has this play between
identity and difference like there's
this constant play where you see the
pattern and but you also notice the
difference dionysus the aria guide
really talks about analogy as
he pulls it into god into these two
extremes you know of of complete
apophatic difference but then also
fullness of of of participation you
could say
and so you use the word metaphorical at
least in the book that i read you you
tend to use the word metaphor in terms
of of that process yes
yes i think it's a reasonable one
because the metaphor is which one is
saying something like he is a lion
and interestingly it depends on the fact
that he's not a lion
if he was it would be a very pronounced
um but the whole point of a metaphor is
that you are bringing together two
things that are simultaneously true in
one way and not true in another
and and i would entirely agree that
metaphors or models and models of just
sort of more elaborated metaphors
govern
how we think about things and are behind
what we mean when we say oh i understand
that including in science so when people
say they understand something i think
what this means is that they can
approximate it in their minds to
something else that they already know
and think that they can believe
so it's really always an analogy as it
were but the analogy is interesting
because of the difference as well
and what i particularly am concerned
about is that when one uses a model such
as a machine to liken anything you make
it look machine like only the bits that
correspond to a machine stand out and
all the rest retires into the sort of
dark into the penumbra but those are the
things we really need to be attending to
otherwise all we do see is the
confirmation of our own model yeah and i
don't know if you thought a little bit
about the obsession with artificial
intelligence at this moment and
in in i seem to notice exactly what
you're saying is that the our obsession
with the technical with computers with
artificial intelligence is actually
transforming
the manner in which we see ourselves we
tend to instead of although we phrase it
as trying to notice the resemblance
between artificial intelligence and
human intelligence there's a manner in
which we've reduced the human being
to you know aggregation of information
we've reduced the human being
to being a kind of dictionary and uh
and and we've reduced consciousness to
what it is that we can see on google
that's error the man in which we engage
with our machines i don't know if you've
noticed that in in terms of the shift in
the way people see the human person
oh i have very much yes
and i suppose 20 or 30 years ago
um
cognitive psychologists
were
consulted about ways in which one could
try and make
a machine smarter by making it like a
person but nowadays the emphasis is how
can we make persons smarter by making
them more like machines
unfortunately we won't make them smarter
and all around me i see the evidence of
what i'd call artificial stupidity which
is the reduction of human intelligence
and so i want to ask you my biggest the
biggest question i want to ask you i
want to get into the cultural question
and i think that you know when i read uh
the master and emissary i think
for me it was it was a very intense
experience
because it was the type of intense
experience
that you get
from
coming close to someone very very close
but then also
also noticing things that that that
how can i say this it's like i wanted to
get into a fight with you reading that
book and that really happens like but i
wanted to get into a fight with you the
way that i would fight with my spouse or
with my good friend because you know it
was like he's like oh you know
sometimes i feel like he's coming he's
right he's there he's there and then i'm
like no no not that not that not that
not that so that's the feeling that i
got and the biggest sense that that for
example i mean i i love so much of it
but the biggest scent the thing that i
want to bring up to you no
hoping that you know how much i
appreciated and loved it was what i
found to be
the profound a profound misunderstanding
of the middle ages like to me that was a
because if you know my work you know
that it is steep very much in the
medieval vision and and all the time
when you were talking about the dark
ages i thought oh
there's a something of of like i
understand the kind of enlightenment uh
line that we have this this vision of
what the the the middle ages brought
but uh but i i felt like there was
a deep misunderstanding and maybe if i
can phrase it the misunderstanding maybe
you can what i thought is a
misunderstanding maybe you can you can
maybe untangle it for me or help me
understand
it's
there's a sense in which
you know you talk about this idea of
conte of context and of into of
integrated meaning how we gather meaning
from all these related intermoving parts
and so you know the the the left brain
tends to want to isolate and to to focus
and to you know to name and to kind of
contain
and
the image you use is the the
representation of the face in through
the ages
one of the images you use and when you
come to the middle ages or to the more
to to the end of the roman empire and
and toward the middle ages you you la
you see the lack of the personal let's
say in the face
and
to me there's something about that which
i i feel like actually the
crystallization of
expression of human expression
is very scientific there's a there's a
there's a very precise science to
crystallizing an expression
whereas i feel like the mimetic aspect
of the face is something that we imitate
through the face that is we imitate the
this this emotional transformation that
we feel in the other we actually imitate
it through our own faces we don't
imitate it by through a pen we imitate
it this way and so but when we come to
imitate nature with a pen
we have to imitate nature within the
space that we're imitating and so the
mimetic aspect of medieval arc is
a good example would be a medieval
manuscript where you have in the center
of the image something highly focused
and highly orthodox so you have an image
of the enunciation for example and then
you will have some let's say flexibility
in that image as well but as you move
towards the margin then you find all the
wonder and idiosyncrasy that would be in
the margins of our of our perception but
would also would be just in the this
kind of metamorphosis uh that you find
in inovated all of these these types of
transformational beings that you see and
so when you go into medieval manuscripts
you look to the borders you find every
single possible imaginative thing you
can think of every idiosyncrasy
inversions humor you know body humor uh
even you know and so
i felt like there's a sense in which in
order to truly understand medieval art
we have to understand it always
contextually itself and so a medieval
sculpture doesn't exist on its own it
exists in a church it exists with the
you know within an architectural meteor
within the participation of a person and
so a good another example would be like
memento mori in the medieval mind
wouldn't have been let's say
a highly
uh
you know highly whimsical use of
anamorphosis in in in holbein's skull
for example but would be the actual
skull of a saint that you would kiss and
that you would venerate and that you
would come to you know and so there's a
sense in which
that is what i think that that's where i
found it difficult in terms of the
middle ages which is that
the the way to understand medieval life
in medieval is through the liturgy not
so much for the art it's through the
life of the people and once and if you
look at ritual and you look at
celebrations and you look at that then
you find something which i feel was much
closer to the i the this kind of ideal
world of of connected participation and
and uh anyway so that's the that is that
i think that was the biggest thing that
i felt when i was reading your book was
like i totally agree with your
conclusion but i felt like in terms of
the the images you used there were some
that i disagreed with
i could feel easy go ahead go ahead go
ahead and knock me down i'm totally
comfortable no no not at all it's not
it's it's absolutely not i hope a matter
of
anyone knocking anybody down um
and and
interestingly uh uh you know i would not
differ from i can't think of anything
you said really that i wouldn't really
accept
um
certainly i think the way in which we
we understand
another person including
their face and so forth is not by a
matter of decoding signals but by a
matter of inhabiting if you like so that
we we feel our way into what it is like
for this person
um and so i completely agree about that
because that's a timeless remark it has
nothing to do with movements in the
history of ideas it's simply how we do
the business of empathizing
but what i was uh talking about was the
different ways in which
um
the history of ideas has taken
cataclysmic turns and i suppose uh i
i absolutely love um very much that
comes out of the middle ages and indeed
it was at my school which which was in a
mid 14th century
um school
uh with a 14th century cloister and
church and so on that i first
in that inhabited way
um
the reality of that medieval world and
its music and its poetry and so on
which i studied so all of that i
completely accept
but my
my point was not
to try and survey the entirety
of um the history but to look at the big
crisis points and i think that the
middle ages i mean they can be seen as
being
very different from the
foregoing
centuries but effectively after the fall
of rome and through to the early
renaissance there was something entirely
continuous going on and it's with the
renaissance that one sees a big shift
and so i'm interested in those big
shifts because i think they're
associated with hemispheric shifts
um
but it this has nothing to do with um
disparagement
and
while i think it's true that to look
for
the expression of the medieval soul one
might look literally rather than in art
per se
that in itself tells you something
um because i wouldn't necessarily say
that was true
of the renaissance i mean there were
wonderful things to do with the liturgy
going on
continuously but but not in quite that
way
um and i love the the
the great business of the medieval mind
is
is the seeing of the multiplicity of
things there's a tendency once one moves
on in time to try and
um make everything consonant but there's
something rather wonderful about the
suggestion of rampant individualization
in the medieval mind and all the detail
and fascinating little jokes that are in
the sculpture and in the in the
manuscripts you mentioned uh memento
mori and i i thought of this if you
don't know it i have to pass this on and
a wonderful
marginal
remark by a french monk who is
transcribing something and
you know there is this
uh moralizing saying
have death in front of your eyes and
said with a french accent this sounds
like abe
oculis
and that can be read as the abbot is
dead in a field and the lily is growing
out of his ass so he he
the scribe actually draws the abbey
prone in the field with the lily coming
out of his house so i i think this is
totally wonderful
one can
bring in every kind of imagination
including the humerus there so i don't
think that i'm somehow
down on the richness of it but i do
think that the emotional expression in
the face at least in the west during the
middle ages
um was not anything remotely like what
came afterwards
and i say in the west because as you
know in the master in his chemistry
um i i
use that extraordinary
image of christ and his mother from the
savior and horror church in in
constantinople now istanbul
um and that was what twelfth century
but yes an amazing thing yes
yeah there was i mean there was in the
byzantine world but there was the thing
about the western medieval
spirit is that it's so difficult to
contain you know because what was
happening in spain what was happening in
northern france was actually quite
different we tend to homogenize it but
there's actually quite a lot of
variability but it's true that there was
a moment in the byzantine
towards the end of the byzantine empire
where there was this high emotionalism
which which kind of brought was brought
into the church and the high expressive
uh use almost caricatural you know uh
facial expressions and and in that
church in particular yeah definitely
um and so i think that that that for me
but i i think that the the
in terms of
because there's okay so so let me bring
it back to the other part which i think
related to the renaissance as well
because in the renaissance what we have
is highly expressive things but which
become more and more passive in terms of
the viewer and so the the the
development of opera the development of
ballet the development of all these arts
which are wonderful and beautiful they
actually bring the viewer into a
position of
of of just passive aesthetic
contemplation and although you can have
internal emotions while you're you're
you're watching as at first maybe the
opera there was some participation
you're allowed to scream at the at the
opera maybe throw things if you were
annoyed um but it gradually was moving
towards what we have now which is the
concert hall which you sit and watch
whereas the
let's say the that's why i i wanted to
bring out the liturgical part which is
that the the liturgical aspect is always
participative right the processions the
the the the celebrations as well you
know and so you celebrate the feast of
this saint which is your the feast of
your local saint and people dress up in
certain colors they you know they dress
up the statue there's this really kind
of dirty uh you know something which is
very formal in its purpose but ends up
being very messy and organic and it's in
its implementation uh which is something
that i feel gets lost in the furthering
centuries
and that leads to like netflix
ultimately which which is just this when
you sit in front of a screen and you
just watch something let's say
well
um i mean that might be a bit of a
conflation but um
even to be talking about opera and
ballet we're pushing things forward
centuries from where we've just been um
and so
and i absolutely agree that what's
wonderful about
the medieval church is this
participatory and celebratory nature of
it and i contrast that in fact um in the
book with what happened with the rise of
protestantism
um the abstraction the verbalization of
experience and not the embodied rituals
which contained
experience that has deep meaning so
that's in other words a move towards
being explicit i would say over implicit
meaning
so i i don't think that you know once
again i'm sorry to disappoint you but i
don't think there's anything here that
we're going to come to blows over um
but i do think that there are some
significant differences i i don't know
about this
uh
observer who's not really taken up into
it i mean even for the sake of argument
let's move forward a few centuries and
talk about opera and ballet and my own
experience of them is a profoundly
moving i mean the
the things in life that can really
earth-shatteringly move me are in fact
occasional experiences in operon ballet
so
um
i i'm not sure quite what you mean you
said internal emotion and i didn't know
quite what an external emotion was but
maybe i misunderstood
no i think what i mean is that so
i think that opera probably can
let's say call you to transformation
like there's some aspect of opera which
calls you for for to transformation but
the liturgical life
is
very much all about transformation a
transformation of the individual
transformation of the community through
the community through this let's say
common action where we are not dancing
per se but we are processing together we
are venerating the same things we are
celebrating you know uh
that that is transformational is is all
is binding the society together
you know as it is
as it is expressing also the little
idiosyncratic realities of being in a
village in spain or being you know
because all these liturgical acts would
also have been somewhat universal
because you could recognize them but
they would also have had a very very
local flavor with you know whatever
idiosyncratic practice that someone in a
little village would develop and so
that's what i mean by this kind of this
call to participation which is which is
not something that you even only
experience alone but we experience
uh
together in the way that we're together
that is
as a village as a community right not as
people sitting in a room watching the
same thing but as the manner in which
you know i have to forgive my brother i
have to deal you know i'm here with my
mother that i fight with all the time
but now we're celebrating this saint
there's something about that that's
pulling me towards something more than
just
my
my experience let's say
there were two things that you you
described there that seem to be very
important though nowadays we might think
of them as contraries but they
are not they need to co-exist one is the
sense of being together over time and
space and the other was of the
idiosyncrasy or the idiom of the local
place which embedded you in that
particular context so in spain or in
france there was something different but
it was still the same liturgy and the
same tradition and so forth
and and the other thing was this idea of
transformation because of course the
other way one can see religious ritual
is in continuity and confirmation of
what there is that it eternally
continues so but that doesn't of course
um mean that it it it can't involve and
and that it should not involve
transformation personal transformation
and i i
keep thinking in terms of the coming
together of opposites because it's a big
theme in my my latest book the matter
with things but you know heraclitus says
this was a mysterious thing by changing
it remains the same which i really
understand
so yes i i i think all those things are
wonderful and important yeah and i think
what that's definitely what i got from
your book is this powerful
this powerful understanding of of how
the one and the many you know need each
other in order to exist
it is there is you can't separate them
they they they have to
they define them they find each other
and we see that in our smallest
experience of anything we view as having
unity we can all immediately see its
parts in its unity and it there's this
breathing back and forth between the the
two aspects and and we tend to over
emphasize
there we tend to radically think to
think that oh we need decentralization
we need we need to
we need
we need to be personal and and original
and everything
or we need to all be the same and
everybody has a number
just so there's this radicalization in
the modern world which takes away from
this organic relationship between
one and many let's say
yes i mean first of all
um what look to us like parts in one
context are holes in another and what
looks like
for now a whole is also a part of
something else so this movement
backwards and forwards between what we
see as a whole and the parts is
terrifically important including
if we pride ourselves on being able to
see the whole
this is not achieved by excluding
recognition of an awareness of the parts
it must actually involve that at the
same time yeah definitely definitely um
and so i think
my biggest question then after these few
little escapades on the middle ages is
what do you see
what do you see as the the way forward
because on the one hand we have an
analysis of the problem and maybe an
abstract
uh
an abstract prognosis of what it is that
should happen let's say that we should
rediscover this but in practice
how do you
how do you see the way forward for us
there's a very good
question and in a way you suppose there
which some of your
listeners or viewers may not know that
um the martian is emissary ends with my
attempt to portray what the world would
look like if we only listen to the sort
of things our left hemisphere can tell
us and very few people have failed to
spot that it's a picture of where we are
now
um
and why that's important is that as i
show in the new book that matter with
things the the right hemisphere sees a
much more vertical picture of the world
takes in a vastly richer picture than
the map
that the sort of skeletal theory of
things which is available to the left
hemisphere
um
i've just been reading
mattis desmet's book the psychology of
totalitarianism
which i think is very good
um and
one of the things he says which is
exactly what i always feel is important
is there are not a few
fixes there are not a couple of things
that we ought to practice and make sure
we do these
often when i've given a talk people want
to know so what are the sort of four
things i need to do and there really
aren't four things as it were we need a
complete shift in consciousness that is
the point and in my terms this means
being aware of all that the right
hemisphere can see that the left
hemisphere rules out but to be more
specific
in the last part the third part of the
matter with things
i
i paint a picture of a cosmos as it
would come to us if we could attend both
with the right and the left hemispheres
one in which the coincidence of
opposites is central
in which this tension between the one
and the many is not to be resolved but
actually it's valuable only because we
can hold that tension so often it's not
collapsing into one or other pole which
is the modern tendency when we see two
things that we think are opposed but
actually holding them both in tension
together and to understand that i i'd
refer sometimes to heraclitus's idea of
the taught string of a liar that gives
the note or the torch string of a bow
that allows the arrow to fly if you let
that tension between two things pulling
apart go the string would just collapse
and there would be no arrow and there
would be no music so we need those
things together
and then i
i changed the way in which we think i
hope about
the so-called building blocks i mean
about things like time and space and
matter and consciousness
but also
putting at the front of things what a
lot of people would think
rather surprising
as choices for constituents of the
cosmos values
purpose
and the sense of the sacred and i think
the loss of these because we've
swallowed
this
very simplistic mechanistic ideology
which which
i'm afraid only leads as desmet suggests
in his book
to
um
a state of anxiety fear loss of the
sense of meaning and cohesion which
causes people to flock towards
totalitarian solutions control and so
forth so what we need is to regain some
sense of the values that i believe are
there in the cosmos the sense of it
having a drive which i think undeniably
does unless you're brainwashed into
believing you can't see such a thing
and
this all-important sense of the sacred
so if you wanted a single phrase it
would be
to
[Music]
re-sacralize our values to certainly
think
of our values as core parts of any
reality that we have and examine what it
is we're valuing
and i draw here as i do in the master
and his emissary on an image which i
find particularly helpful which is
the pyramid of values suggested the
hierarchy of values suggested by the
german
phenomenological philosopher max
schaeler who i think is is very profound
and and he describes these different
tiers of value with um at the very
bottom layers of utility and pleasure
and at the top the sense of the sacred
and it seems to me that we live in a
world in which you've totally inverted
these things and all that matters is
utility and pleasure and that all these
other things which don't just include
the sense of the sacred but
um
just under the sense of sacred is the
idea of beauty truth and goodness my
goodness i'm going to say what has
happened to truth in these times what
has happened to goodness what has
happened to beauty
and below that but still above utility
and
pleasure
values such as
courage magnanimity generosity
fidelity
uh these things that it seems to me are
also part of the the bonfire of things
that we think we can do without but
actually are part of why life is worth
living at all yeah and so i don't know
in your thinking about this if you
thought a bit about dante um
one of the
because one of the the
the elements that i tried to bring about
is first of all the the element of of
imitation and then the the element of
celebration
and so
one of the one of the things about
humans is that we don't we don't
celebrate uh values we celebrate people
we celebrate
places we celebrate events we celebrate
memories we celebrate things that
participate in our life
and so the reason why i bring up dante
is that what dante seems to do is that
he seems to join this hierarchy of
virtues
with a ontological hierarchy of saints
and angels and so it's not just about
celebrating the virtue but it is about
finding
imitation you know and so being pulled
up by beatrice being pulled up by by uh
by bernardo clairvaux and it's by and
it's through these celebratory
imitations that we actually
are pulled into participation and
there's something
you know there's something about the the
platonic
way of formulating it which
i think is
makes it difficult for humans to to do
that and and that's why i mean i guess
that's
as you know i'm expl i'm very much a
christian and i and i think that in the
in the christian participation they were
able to take what was best of the
platonic good
and these this hierarchy of virtues but
then joined them
to
actual
imitation and celebration and
participation and so the
the the
so that i guess i i my big question is
do you think that the the way back to
this is religious or do you propose
rather a irreligious or a religious
way to for us to re-embrace these
these ways of being
well um
i think that
fundamentally we do need
a religious cult of mind i i
i
have to be careful because
which is why i wrote a very long book
showing people what i'm not saying
because there is an immediate reflex in
many people's minds now to shut down as
soon as one mentions religion
um and in this country which is a
godless country compared with
america no doubt canada
if you ask people
do they belong to a religion about 13 of
them say that they do
um so 87 are not but if you ask people
do you think there's more to this
life and to this world than is accounted
for in the reductionist materialist
picture 95 of them say yes so people are
missing something extremely powerful
and what is
wonderful in what you said and i
completely endorse and have written
about in a number of places
is this idea of being attracted forwards
to something that we wish to imitate
and it's in complete contrast to the
mechanistic
universe in which we are to play things
of causality in which things from behind
as it were
push us forward
and i contrast this with the idea of an
ideal of something that appeals to us
that draws us forwards we may feel a
huge gap between us and whatever that
ideal might be i mean in the middle ages
the immutation christi the imitation of
christ and the sense of an ideal of
course one's not asked to be
those ideals because that's not possible
but to feel the pull
and never to disparage that pool and to
live in the full
meaning of that gravitational force on
one's life so i think that's a a
brilliant idea and in just to finish
because you mentioned so many things uh
plato
i mean in one sense of course what is
common there between that
picture and the one of medieval
christianity with dante
and plato would be the idea of these
attractive
ideals because i think plato thought
that we were called forward to these
things we we sensed them and we wanted
to be with them and like them but the
bit that is not is the disparagement of
all that is material of the whole
business of the incarnate world and my
god the whole point of christianity is
that god became incarnate i mean it's
absolutely the central part of that
religion and along with it the much
misunderstood idea of redeeming
carnality
uh taking it back into into heaven in
the idea of resurrection yeah
no definitely i think that that's
that's something when people
point to the very to the platonic uh
vision of christianity which which we
have to be honest has does poke its head
up once in a while where we do have a
disparaging of the body and we do have a
disparaging of
of of this incarnate principle but i
think that once in a while
no i
it
a central part of christianity to our um
consternation but there we are yeah but
i think i think that there's there's
also a difference between let's say a
tendency towards asceticism which we
definitely do see in in christianity but
then that let's say the bodily
celebration will happen
will happen
in the forums like it'll happen in the
the colorful processions in the you know
if you think about we often have a very
strange image of what the middle ages
were like the middle ages everybody
belonged to all these associations and
in groups and they all had all these
very strange practices and there was
something about you know you know
holding the relic of a dead person you
know having this there's so this direct
connection uh
to to to uh to embodiment and mortality
which was which was uh you know the the
whole idea of the um
of the uh the miracle um at the
cathedral the miracle of uh of uh
why is it that i forget the name of the
name
i'm sorry i forget the name of the of
the saint the saint that was killed in
the cathedral by by the king uh
though the miracle right he was it was
his body that was plunged into a into a
tub and they had they'd killed him and
then they would let leak the water out
of that tub and people would drink it to
their and it's like that is
that is not the incarnation that is
actually quite scandalous almost tantric
you know vision of like of of uh of the
body and our participation in it so i
think i think that it's true i do see
that there is in
there has been a tendency towards a kind
of dualism
in uh in the christian tradition but
there is also a lot of space to bring
out the incarnational aspect and i mean
more so i think also in the in the
eastern tradition there really is this
this celebration of the transfiguration
and the resurrection very much so so
exactly i was just going to say
this all this is much more present at
least now in the eastern tradition of
the greek and the orthodox
russian
and romanian orthodox churches
so um
yes and of course
what one
needs to be able to preserve if possible
is the sense that
you know flesh is not something simply
to see
as
abject
and to be as it were if possible got rid
of but also not to see it as central or
absolutely essential to whatever it is
one means
by the living spirit or soul
of the person so
again it's one of these holding
togethers of things that don't seem
immediately um to cohere
i um
i don't know whether i'm i can call
myself a christian or not i i'm rather
lives to make such a grand claim
um
and i know that it's perfectly all right
to acknowledge one's complete failure to
be a good christian and still call
oneself a christian but i i i certainly
draw enormously spiritually from the
christian tradition how could one
absolutely not it's so fantastically
rich
and it was that really that drew me to
it in my teens having been brought up in
a family where religion played no part
at all
um so much so that by the end of my
teens i planned to become a monk which
really i didn't i didn't i didn't know
that
no no i my idea was to go to oxford
study philosophy and theology and then
probably go into a monastic order and
fortunately for any monastic order and
for myself um this plan changed and
i don't think i'd have fitted in very
well but really the only reason i'm sort
of mentioning that is to say that i
suppose my position
which i think is is
a very important part of the way i look
at things is a panenthist position
not pantheism which simply as you know
means that everything is god and god is
everything that's the sum of everything
but that god is
not
god is in everything and everything is
in god which leaves
room for god to be more than we can know
or say by just summing everything that
we believe to be real
but yeah i think that that position is
definitely
in tune with with the the more mystical
aspect of the eastern tradition you know
you really do have an apathetic vision
of of god which is central to
to to all the mythical practices in the
eastern church
and then but then there is also like you
said there is this filling up which you
i think that that's what you see in in
dionysus the arapah guide so clearly is
that he he does these two extreme
movements where he he says no you cannot
say anything which touches god god is
beyond all definitional name well you
know being non-being he's he's beyond
all things but at the same time he is to
be found everywhere and
and hidden behind all phenomena you know
you know things that yes yes yeah yeah
um
i must say i'm
i probably more than you
um
adherent to the idea of
hypothesis of the apathetic
tradition
which presented me with a problem
because at the end of the
the recent book um which occupied me
over the last decade or so the matter
with things at the end i have this
chapter on the sense of the sacred which
is i think over 100 pages long so it's
really a short book
and i started it knowing that anything
that one says about god is going to be
wrong and that therefore whatever i said
was going to be in some ways
either an idol that got between
one and god or
at least a distraction
and a falsehood
but the alternative was to say nothing
at all about it and that seemed to me
actually a greater betrayal of it
because it's better to as it were fail
the best you can and acknowledge the
extent of your failure than to say
nothing although i was advised by
very kind friends and colleagues don't
include this chapter you know the book
contains a lot of interesting philosophy
but people will stop taking you
seriously if you write a chapter on the
sacred
um but anyway at the end of the day i
did
so there we are yeah but i think we're
in an interesting position right now in
terms of the current let's say
intellectual
space where the the notion of
apophaticism when you look at at uh you
know the developments in cognitive
science and the way in which people are
seeing the limits of definitions and are
talking about complexity and emergence
the notion of
apophatic thinking
is just it has to to rush back in
because we realize that there's almost
like a fractal apatheticism where
although we tend to talk about
apophaticism in terms of god there's
also a phenomenological apopheticism
which is that all things present
themselves as always more than what than
what they are and so there's they all
call you there's this calling behind all
phenomena which i think heidegger was
was wanting us to
to get a sense of with his idea of
design and so so it seems like it's a
good time to talk about that
no i agree completely and of course
interestingly
um
the apathetic path is the path that is
taken by science itself science can
never say this is the case it can only
say that as we see things now we can say
that the following things
are not the case so in other words it's
all it's always um alerting us to things
that we should not prefer but is unable
to say this is the truth
yeah and that's interesting because
although that is ingrained in the
scientific
method itself it oh it's always betrayed
in its popular
the way it's presented in the in popular
world it's always about you know science
says this and you know so now we follow
this line yes um
i i wonder if you agree with me but
sorry i just say um i don't know if you
agree with me but i i think that a lot
of this is due to the prevalence
of um
talking heads from the biological world
i'm very impressed by the modesty of
physicists and their
utter readiness to acknowledge the
extent of their
understanding
but um
there are a number of people who've uh
become used to the idea that they're
obviously very good at molecular biology
and that this gives them the authority
to pronounce on whether there's a god or
not yeah
who won't name any names yeah so i i
think you're probably right absolutely
not yeah
i think you're you're you're probably
right uh there is something i mean i'm
from the the during the entire 20th
century there's a sense in which some of
the physicists had very deep mystical at
least insight or at least a kind of
mystical reserve uh facing the facing
the way phenomena was presenting itself
to them
yes in discussing matter and
consciousness i i quote many of the
great physicists of the last century and
as you probably know there's hardly a
single one in fact i can't think of one
who does who doesn't really embrace this
idea that consciousness is a ontological
primary
um which doesn't necessarily mean that
it is
prior to matter but that it is an
ontological primary in the sense that
you can't get behind it and say that
it's derived from something else
i think to have a dispute about matter
and consciousness may be a mistake
if one's arguing that consciousness is
um prior to match i think that case can
be made and i'm sympathetic to it but i
think at the moment what i hold is that
they are in fact different phases of the
same phenomenon much as ice and
steam
and the flowing liquid are all
manifestations of water if you say which
one is the real water which came first
well there isn't an answer to that
question they're all
completely different manifestations of
the same thing with utterly different
qualities but they are effectively the
same yeah and i mean a simple
formulation of that would be
either you see in scripture that it says
in the beginning god created heaven and
earth and those two primary categories
whether you see it as the dao or as the
yin yang for example has these two
primary categories
they don't you know they are in a way a
manifestation of something apophatic
behind it but as they appear they appear
as two
two opposites in attention that that
could play with each other and that
communic how can i say they one
expresses the other and the other you
know finds body in in the other and
there's this this interplay so so i
think that that's something
yeah it's something that is there in in
in basic just theological thinking i
think
it is and it's embraced by the idea of
pananthism
um and in
in in my
thinking uh the idea that the cosmos and
the divine principle
um are constantly in an act of
co-creation that's very important this
is an idea that was articulated by
uh alfred north whitehead
who i hold in considerable esteem
um
yeah well i i'd probably struggle a
little more with whitehead in the sense
that i think that
there's yeah there's a manner in which
let's say the revelation of the divine
principle at least for a christian from
a christian perspective the revelation
of the divine principle will happen in
this almost like intercourse right you
have this almost sexual imagery in
scripture between the bride and the
bright room between between the two
aspects uh uh but that there is let's
say the infinite is beyond behind that
or you know the there is a there is an
apophatic
emptiness or source out of which this
this this play kind of comes into being
uh
which is which at least in scripture is
represented as the let's say the first
moment of creation and so
so you have heaven and earth but you
have something which is beyond behind
you know the the that is the source of
both of that opposite just so we don't
fall into a kind of duality
a dualism no well i
i no i think we're not not to exactly um
i
i i suppose my belief about
the divine are
precessual
um so i believe that the divine creation
is a process in fact i believe that all
things are processes what we call things
are in fact
ways of nominalizing processes and
making us think that they're somehow
distinct and separate from other things
others processes
but i think what you're possibly trying
to do
um which i would sympathize with is
maintain the possibility because after
all
we agreed that ordinary language won't
encompass the divine that we can have an
idea of god as
eternal and as something that is
constantly coming into being
well i guess i think so but at least
that's the way that i would see it and i
would see let's say
the divine story or this a good image
that you see in in scripture you have
this grand story right where you you
have this movement from the garden to
the city and this filling up of the
world with presence and so it starts
with a the seed with a tree in the
natural world and it ends with this
glorious uh shining uh filling up of
even human activity with this with this
you know with with a divine presence you
could say but it is like an idealized
vision of this process of filling up of
the world with with uh with the divine
principle um
[Music]
yeah
i don't know about perhaps i
question but i don't want to get into
legalistic
matter of procedure but i don't know
about filling up
um suggesting that at some point it
wasn't
filled
i mean my idea of process is not that
something becomes
um to a greater degree divine but that
the divine becomes to a greater degree
what it is see what i mean so it's not a
matter of filling up something that was
formally an imperfection by adding in
some more divinity but but instead that
the divine is itself something
that is
eternally
um something that can be un unfolded
without in any way damaging its
integrity in fact yeah no i i definitely
agree and you could see it almost like
as a you could see the story uh as an
intersection within
within god like it it's it's like you
see it we see it as a slice of something
which is eternally happening and
eternally true but because of our
because of our position you know we just
see this as this line a point there and
a point there and a in the through line
but ultimately it is something which is
eternally
happening or not either word happening
even doesn't doesn't account for what it
is we're
um
and so i guess i i guess
let's say
if you had advice to give to to the
people that are listening in terms of
what you feel
that they should be
attending to or doing or
or because it's
the project of having a radical
change of consciousness is a pretty big
project and and i think that it can seem
so big that for people reading or for
people listening they'll feel like well
what am i gonna what am i gonna do then
because the world it seems like
especially
in the last few years things have gotten
much worse uh with cobit and the
reaction to kobit and you know this
there's the totalitarian
spirit has
felt itself very uh let's say pressing
down on pressing down into us and uh and
also a way we've also felt a
a willingness to it to to to embrace it
out of a fear of anxiety of danger and
anxiety of
of uncertainty and so what do you
suggest for people that they could do in
their in their lives
yes well
what i'm going to say is is probably not
terribly satisfactory but i i do rather
hold with desmet that i mean i'm very
glad to hear him say specifically what i
also believe that it's no good thinking
of one or two things we can do
we need to move to a different in
a vision of who we are and what the
cosmos is which will enable us
to rediscover
the integrity of experience to
rediscover
the sense of value purpose direction
which is not something i believe that we
paint on
to
the universe
something inside our head we will paper
it in a pleasant way in order to make
ourselves feel better about being in
this terrific prison of the skull i
don't believe that at all i believe that
we are in fact when we're experiencing
we are in touch with something that is
entirely real we only see part of it of
course
a very small part but the part that we
do see is nonetheless
real even if it's not the all
and and that these things need
can be rediscovered but not piecemeal um
i mean the nearest i can get pieces meal
is we'll try um mindfulness meditation
for half an hour every day but that's
not a very satisfactory answer either so
i'm going to give them the most
unsatisfactory answer but
quite honestly the best answer i'm sorry
to say this
but it might be worth reading
the matter with things if you can bear
to because the whole point of that
undertaking
was precisely to take somebody who
couldn't see
anything here beyond the reductionist
materialist paradigm
and take them by logical steps that they
can acknowledge
to a place where instead of thinking
only
somebody with
an educ lack of education or very simple
minded would believe in the the sacred
and the divine nowadays
i want them to arrive there and think
that only somebody who's rather simple
minded or not very well educated would
jump to the conclusion
that there's nothing in this sacred that
one really needs to try and approach it
and of course one will never know it
unless one puts oneself in the way of
doing so which means opening oneself to
it so it's no good waiting for it to
come and knock on your door you have to
not sort of
you have to do what i call active
receptivity so you have to attend
in a manner that will allow something to
come into being in the space that you
have opened by your receptive attention
i believe this is how
artists are able to conceive their works
of art and i believe it's how we
get to understand
the
existence of the sacred
um i think it's what is meant by prayer
probably
the this attention this open attention
in which one's not talking
to or about
god but actually listening
um i think this is a very important
thing attention is at the core of it and
i know you yourself think attention is
very important i call attention a moral
act because
the kind of attention we pay changes the
world it changes what is there to find
and it also changes us in the process
of attending
and i think here of uh two french
philosophers of the last century one
very well known simon vay who said that
attention is the you know to pay
attention is the greatest act of
generosity
and that it it
mediates our ability to understand the
the what comes to us through prayer and
louis lavelle saying that love is a pure
attention to the existence of the other
i think this is
brilliant and important and so paying
that attention is necessary how to do
that what i'm hoping is that after
reading
what i have to say people will feel
that experience and i'm emboldened to
say this by the fact simply
um that people keep writing to me and
saying since reading your work i i can't
not see the world in a certain way
it's changed my sense of
of my life it's changed my my
relationships it's changed my work and
now i see everything through this
different
lens so if somebody says well can you
hand me the lens i say yes
it's out there
yeah and i think that i think that what
you're saying is the idea of attention
is is a very simple and perfect way to
help people
understand because like you said you you
i can you can explain it to for a
certain amount amount of time
but then you know the everybody knows
what it means to pay attention to at
least to a certain extent but if you
start to practice it you know and you
can see the difference especially if you
have a family if you have kids you know
you can
you pay attention to your kids like real
attention
yes that's it's transformational and
then they don't people say you need to
spend time with the kids like no you can
pay attention to your child for 15
minutes and they will go on their way
and play alone they'll be happy because
they will have gotten that that that
connection that they're looking for
it's a kind of magic
um it bestows something on whatever one
is attending to it brings it to life and
the trouble is that one's attention
is valuable to
capitalism everybody wants a grab of
your attention to buy their thing but
this is to to reduce one of the greatest
things that exists
um to some
[Music]
to desecrate it to trail it through the
mud and say no it's just about listening
to what i've got to say what you've got
to say this jingle
this this message from your machine
the way to achieve it is to switch all
that off and empty your life out i mean
i
i i
i'm not saying certainly that i've got
anything
you need to model i i i'm not very good
at any of this but i do actually live
in a place where i can't get a mobile
signal at all i you can't get a
television signal or you could i suppose
with a satellite but i don't
um
and so i have an enormous amount of
peace outside there is a very beautiful
world in which things are speaking to me
if i allow them to speak and don't over
over um explain or or talk to them but
just open to their
their being so there is some kind of
commerce that is vivifying that comes
about through one's
attention to the world and as you say it
is it is a generative act
well i think that that's a beautiful
place to to finish our conversation i
think people can
can leave with a with uh with a nice
little
a nice little nugget of wisdom that they
can apply in their lives uh so so dr
mcgill chris thank you so much for your
time and for for meeting with me was it
was a wonderful conversation
well well thank you so much london i
very much enjoyed it